hey what's up guys hope you're all doing
well and thanks for the feedback on the
last video since I've been unable to go
to the barber and I needed a haircut I
tried to cut my own hair about a week or
so ago yep I went and did it for the
first time ever in my life I posted some
pictures on my Instagram profile but I
also filmed it and spit it up to show
you guys a little bit of the process
that I went through I'm going to cut my
hair if I mess it up I'm probably just
gonna have to shave my whole head it
took a little bit of time for me to
coordinate myself and not cut my hand
but after a while I got it I only cut
around three-quarters of an inch off the
top and the sides but I think it'll have
to do for now
today I'm gonna show you how to make two
awesome paper planes the pelican and the
dive bomber and I named it that way
because of the way they fly check it out
the dive bomber is a really cool glider
that can fly around 40 or 45 feet with a
good throw it sometimes dives or shoots
down but I'll show you later how you can
adjust and throw it for optimal distance
and smooth flight the Pelican on the
other hand is a cool stunt plane that
specializes in doing front flips and
then flies upside down back to you I
named it the Pelican because the birds
are known to dive down into the water to
get fish it can also fly like a glider
but it's mostly made for stunts and
doesn't go too far with some practice
and adjustments that I'll show you at
the end you can get the Pelican to do
some really amazing stunts and you'll
amaze everyone with your new plane video
and my community post for the planes
you'll need two sheets of printer paper
colored or white and once you have that
we can get started I'm going to first
show you how to make the dive bomber or
if you want to learn how to make the
Pelican then I will put a little
subtitle down here that you can go to in
the video start with your paper in the
landscape orientation or the longer edge
is horizontal and take the left edge and
fold it across to the right edge line
them up as neatly as possible and just
make a crease on the left side here and
just run your fingernail against it to
make sure it's extra sharp then we can
open it up and we're going to take both
of the corners and fold them on to this
vertical line so just take it an
airplane fold it in to the center so
that it's directly on the vertical line
and just make a crease on the upper
right to just run your fingernail over
the right side and just do the same with
the other side making sure the crease is
sharp now
to take the very top and fold it down to
the corners so just take the tip and
round it off and line it up directly
with the corners here and once it's
folded down we can make a nice sharp
crease on the top then we could unfold
the tip and you'll see we now have a
horizontal line here we're going to take
the tip and fold it directly on to that
center point so just line it up with the
center of that horizontal line and make
a nice sharp crease on the top now we
could take the top edge here and fold it
directly in onto the vertical line that
we already have just gonna set it down
and fold it in line it up as neatly as
you can and make a nice sharp crease all
throughout the right side once again
crease it really sharp with your finger
now and now we could do the same with
the left side fold it directly in crease
it all throughout and sharpen it then we
could just fold the whole thing in half
by taking the left side and folding it
to the right side flattening everything
out and you should have something that
looks just like this looking near the
nose of the plane you should see a
vertical crease in the paper we're going
to fold the wings down horizontally so
we create a crease that lines up with
the top of that vertical one when you
fold the wing down you'll also notice
there is a horizontal crease on the
opposite wing that you can use as a
guide fold the front wing down until it
aligns with the top of that vertical
line and the opposite horizontal line
and just make sure that the back of the
wing lines up with the body as well
somes gonna set it down and make a nice
sharp crease along the edge now that we
folded the front wing we could do the
back wing so just flip it over and do
the same thing fold it and line it up
with the other one just like this and
make a nice crease along the top once
your plane looks like this we can move
on finally we're going to fold the wing
tips upwards horizontally at the corner
here just fold it up and be sure to
check that the back of the wing tip is
also aligned with the wing don't worry
if it's not exactly folded on that
corner what's most important is that
both sides of the plane are symmetrical
or evenly matched just flip the plane
over fold the other wing tip up until it
matches the opposite one and we
completed the dive-bomber
we can just lift the wings up so that
they're horizontal or slightly
angled upwards lift the wing tip so that
are perpendicular to the wings and it's
ready to be thrown to make the Pelican
we're also going to hold the paper in
the landscape orientation and take the
left edge and line it up with the right
edge once they're neatly aligned then we
can make a nice sharp crease along the
left side of the paper then we can open
the paper up and take the top edge and
fold it down to the bottom edge but
we're just going to hold it there and
make a dimple on the top edge by
pressing in the middle here like this
then we can open up the paper and you'll
see we now have a horizontal dimple at
the halfway point we can then take the
bottom edge and fold it up to that
dimple hold it there and now make a
dimple on the bottom now when you open
up the paper you'll see we have two
dimples one in the middle and one on the
bottom we'll take the top edge fold it
down to the lower dimple and make a
sharp crease all throughout the top edge
of the paper now we're going to take the
corner on the right and fold the right
edge down onto this edge that we just
folded down just fold it in line it up
and crease sharply on the upper right do
the same thing on the left side fold it
in line it up on the bottom and give it
a nice crease unfold both of the corners
we're going to open up the edges on the
right and do an inside reverse fold so
spread the edges apart and press
downwards on the top push the edge
inwards and give this diagonal fold a
little pinch then flatten the paper out
by pressing downwards on it do the same
on the left open the edges press down on
the top and tuck the center in while
pinching the diagonal and flattening it
out we're going to take this triangular
flap here on the right side and flatten
it to the left like this by flipping it
then we could take this right edge here
and fold it directly onto this vertical
crease on the right side of the triangle
so I'm just going to place it down and
fold the right edge here directly onto
that existing line making a nice sharp
crease on the right now we can take the
flap and flip it back towards the right
directly on top of the edge we just
folded and flatten everything out repeat
the same on the left side fold the left
flap to the right now
take the edge beneath it and fold it on
to that vertical crease on the left of
the triangle then flip the triangle back
and flatten everything out now you
should have something that looks like
this
now we can flip the entire sheet upside
down and we're going to fold the
airplane in half by taking the right
side and folding it to the left press
downwards on it again and if you
flattened it well like I did you should
sort of see a light horizontal crease
here starting from the corner we're
gonna fold the wings down by taking the
corner here and aligning it with the
bottom making sure that the front of the
plane lines up with itself
don't try to line the top of the wing
with the bottom only pay attention to
this horizontal crease here and the
corner in front when we're folding it
down so just fold it down lining up the
front of it with itself just like that
and give the wing a nice crease on top
now the front of it should look just
like this we're going to flip it over
and align the other wing with that one
that we just folded line them up and
just crease it on top sharply hold the
front of it towards you and flip it
upside down like this and pull it open
flatten it out at this point take the
top of the plane and fold it down to
this bottom edge the paper will be
pretty thick here so once you fold it
down let's make sure it's really flat by
applying a lot of pressure and creasing
sharply now flip the paper over again so
the flaps are on the bottom and take the
right side and fold it to the left and
flatten it out
you should see that there is a
horizontal crease here that we made
before when we folded the wings down
we're just going to simply fold the
wings down on that existing crease and
do the same for the other wing fold it
down and flatten the plane you should
notice that they match up evenly open
the plane and hold it here on the body
and flip it over and you'll notice on
the bottom here we have these little
triangles that stick out these work like
elevators that disturb the airflow we're
just going to fold them upwards all the
way just like this crease it do the same
with the left one
now we could fold the triangle the
opposite way or downwards on that
existing crease it will be pointing
directly towards the ground when you
hold the plane repeat on the left side
on the underside of both the wings
you'll see those flaps sort of stick out
here and we're going to fold the right
one at this corner and fold it towards
us try to fold the triangular flap so
that the bottom of it is parallel with
the front or nose of the plane and make
a nice sharp crease on the right we're
then going to lift the tip of the flap
up so it's facing directly upwards when
we hold the plane do the same on the
left one fold it towards you at the
corner make the bottom line up with the
nose crease it and open it so it's
pointing straight upwards and now you're
done with the Pelican it should look
just like this with those tips facing
straight up and those small triangular
elevators in the back pointing down to
the ground so let's go over how to throw
them I'm not sure why but I'm having a
little difficulty with this plane when I
throw it I'm not sure if the humidity
got to it but when I throw it it's kind
of circling back a little bit I'm not
going far
[Music]
Wow it's not supposed to be a boomerang
plane I don't know if they've just
become a little humid but they're not
flying properly anymore this is the one
that I was throwing in the beginning of
the video and if you look at it now it
is kind of messing up it became really
flimsy this one I literally just made
and it is flying well so I just kind of
tilt these up and oh what I'm going to
do is basically hold it right here
behind the nose in the middle of the
plane almost and I'm just going to toss
it out like this do not throw it too
hard go like this it's all in the elbow
not too much your arm
[Music]
you could also try to throw the
dive-bomber upside down like this if you
want to throw the pelican just make sure
that everything is creased really
sharply and that these are facing up and
these two are facing down and just throw
it straight out sort of like a
basketball not too hard but just throw
it out and up a little bit just like
this
Oh again it's mostly in the elbow to
make it kind of fly straight you can
just flatten these out like this and
then just give it a nice soft toss maybe
just a little harder there we go
and finally if you fold these all the
way upwards like this and toss it up it
might do a back flip yep there you go
[Music]
I hope you like the video for the
Pelican and the dive bomber if you did
be sure to give it a thumbs up down
below and hit the subscribe and
notification bell I had a few problems
with the dive bomber I think because I
left it out and it got really damn so
make a new one and be sure not to let it
sit out in humidity let me know what
you'd like to see next in the comments
below boomerangs planes thanks again for
watching and I'll see you soon